hello happy opening to Blizzard world
new don't we have a poster or did you
not come I did I did yes we screwed up
we had the poster and we didn't even put
it up so as everyone in chat is probably
guessing and/or waiting for we are also
doing the waiting game where we're in
line um yeah we're basically in line to
buy our tickets no we we have our ticket
we have our tickets we got our opening
day we got all of our merch
everything update literally doing the
update now opening the doors Pro move
right there so the updates happening I
can show it to you and prove it to you
there's the launcher it's doing the
patch now hopefully it's it's fetching
so we're waiting in line we're so hyped
to get in but we have to wait we don't
know we don't have a Fastpass we don't
have anything on VIP but I feel like we
can see like the ticket holders right
there and we're bound to use a family
with five children all in strollers oh
yeah
damn them there's a there's like
multiple ladies with bags and purses bag
check have 70 bags they all need to talk
let's check out those skins let's do it
there's Blizzard world boom oh thank god
it works oh hey I kind of went on faith
that Blizzard would be on time here we
go oh and music oh do you need a second
to why you're alright I'm going to turn
up the music you guys can listen to
music while he buys boxes obviously
can't show you his account while he's
buying boxes I believe it's just so
they're just normal boxes um they're not
like a special special excuse me like
event-based box so it's not like
Blizzard World boxes Michael Hardy are
ready on the on the ticket they're
joining up on us so we're gonna buy 50
boxes we're gonna do what we always do
between me and Joey we're gonna play
couple games on the new map and then we
will open our boxes after that I'll let
me switch back to the you have them now
right
glue anyways we're gonna go look at the
scans let's go look at the skins that's
what everyone is these are so good
also I'm gonna preface this by saying we
always show the skins and then people go
show the skins again so we're gonna show
them now and then you can always come
back to them later alright first even
last one those those shown Aviva get
blackhead pretty good got tail Mick has
a cool oh that's so good
I only saw some of them I know they kind
of like preview sneak print listen okay
so we'll go with the legendary ones that
they showed off okay most recently all
right so there's the diva one there was
a gun different whatever would check
that yeah we'll check it yeah Hanzo he
also has one oh he's got the Kabuki
where is it
kabuki pretty good looks really good
okay looks good whoever looks so nice it
looks like his bow that doesn't look
that different to me but it's got some
subtle touches right here where is he
capoeira nice nice
okay his gun looks really nice oh yeah I
want to see that like in action bouncing
around oh yeah I just noticed - uh thank
you more ex plays it's a thousand
credits which is not bad because the
event stuff is usually three thousand so
like no no if you if you notice that
none of these have like a special icon
next to it devs are just like they like
that in the game base game in the base
they're not gonna go away if you what
would have been your backup plan if it
didn't work stall for time and chat with
you guys and then just talk about how
long the line was to get Jeff Caplan oh
yeah we that one time I had to put up
like multiple doses event I don't
remember who is Erica that's the fourth
one it was there only for well for for
the most recent ones that they got
showed okay you're still in your mom's
basement right yes life games always in
the basement ass this looks really nice
to her crown that she wears
oh yeah yeah I like I hit that little
the Anubis kind of thing the wings
good detail weapon looks good too yeah
see it's nice to see the like more care
into the some of these Legendary's
because some of them like there's been
some Legendary's have done have been a
little bit more suspect where we're like
it's like it's a new style but it's like
casual or somewhat creepy wanna come
down crazy yes also surgeries reapers
symmetric so we have royal here okay
yeah good
i was when i saw that i was like there's
no way that's legendary right the only
difference is like little glowy here
yeah and then his a garment or i don't
know it's like almost his shawl his
shawl yeah thank you has like the big
old like dead eye reapers though is I'm
surprised this is only jessic only
because of how cool it looks just
thought the face mask in the the back is
pretty sweet i I'm not buying that one
though actually I could afford it it's
only 250 yeah yeah that's a bargain
three chief its bargain Oh Symmetra
house ones thanks I think there was more
like isn't there like Azaria yeah so so
door actually really like this one in
the iridescent green and purple with a
blue and purple on that thanks also
shout out to uh we'll see him later but
shoutouts to a Joey's wife who helped do
some of the sticker or the spring raise
that you'll see here in a little bit so
shout outs a little bit okay so we're
gonna go into the the new Blizzard world
wizard world skins sick really good
oh yeah it's kind of it's Protoss II
yeah yeah so they're all themed after
other Blizzard properties so this one
obviously Starcraft yeah it looks really
nice the Nova Widow is like legit like
just like pretty spot-on for like what
you would imagine right that the ghost
the sniper so black hand do this yep
World of Warcraft that's a really good
one
oh my god this looks good looks just
like wow Armour the shoulders especially
surprising that his other shoulder isn't
equally as big but that's fine
I mean it's make sense cuz he has one
big clubbing fist you know remember at
the moment road hog there we go we got
one here so not everybody got a skin
then oh yeah is it bullets yet oh man I
gotta buy that skin is really good B I
played so much Diablo man I got to have
the butcher's cleaver man that is lush
meat right here stitches all over the
place meat there's a Winston one someone
said I think I don't know if that's true
or not I'm just reading chat also yeah
thank you guys for tuning in I will be
reading chat as Joy plays alive every
day at 11:00 bunch of stuff going on
this week he has a carbon fiber skin oh
I like that was pretty cool I like that
for 250 runs one can be 50 he's got the
little slit because I just like the
difference in his helmet yeah yeah I
like that all right sorry the Barbarian
right and Diablo as well I think is it
yeah barbarian yep that's pretty spot-on
to like Sonia from the from Diablo 3 so
that's cool I think that's one of the
ones Mike Mike wants oh please that the
gold version but still it's still the
detail right there that looks really
sick we haven't checked mercy someone
said Winston Winston does he have one
yeah we got tricked now we got true no
we got tricked Widow widows got Nova
yeah from Starcraft BAM that straight up
it's just straight up Nova she's made it
into the into the game yeah I'm guessing
is very similar to yeah I know was
actual gun
it's just Torbjorn we're doing okay yeah
yeah they're like he has a
Magne okay so like ad world it's also a
world of warcraft Magni is a is actually
like like if you play heroes of the
storm there's a yeah I think it's Magni
Bronzebeard I think so yeah yeah any
sense
speaking of heroes of the storm did you
see that anime yeah that was cool oh my
god I got the feel while watching that
if you guys haven't seen yet go look it
up because it's nothing for soldier
either I'm guessing for Sombra trying to
remember I'll go through them anyway
just to double-check we'll check around
hard to in a second for you guys just
like a possession case was this I can't
remember
maybe maybe sombras glitches is a
Shriner remember to be honest shows you
how much I actually play Sombra you
check out you haven't take soldier oh we
made yeah she does so she has the one
from legendary though I mean there's a
lot of detail here yeah in terms of like
how if you really like this short and
like liked her outfit there this would
be better if she had like the one we're
like right after she wakes up where it's
the just like the t-shirt yeah this one
this to me I know they did a lot there
but like it's it's not doing it for me
as a legendary I guess but if maybe like
you said if you like the short a lot
then yeah it's like young me or whatever
or younger me I guess check Reinhardt
and Genji after you guys are painful
thanks thanks Afghan Ross you're also
painful I hope you have this one he does
he is the young Reinhardt so he doesn't
have the scar he solos both eyes yeah
you know back when he was a hockey lad
also [ __ ] you should also watch that
short if you haven't watched that short
when can I dual wield them hammers
though that's what I want to know please
alright
do you know which intros are in the
thingy like intros and emotes
have to go have to check I'm surprised
they don't say like new on here it's
gonna be hard to tell
yeah you have to go digging in a little
bit later we showed IVA earlier G&K
so if you want to check that out it was
at the beginning of the stream i know
djinji okay unfortunately no bash in
mercy knows nothing probably don't see
anything
defense matrix was this one I feel like
that has to be newer cuz like isn't like
the it's like the new abilities okay
there should really keep like a little
yeah we should have I should have been
better prepared that's my fault the
patch is out
Benedict League you can hop in as long
as you can download it I haven't checked
on console so you guys can kind of help
me out or someone in the workplace I can
hit up Nick Margarito's I'm sure he's
checking out the I know he just got this
one right here
oh no he does yes one yeah Oh awesome
tape one that one's actually pretty cool
look at this tire
there's gun did more I have one right
now Moira Oh find out yeah
no just two new yeah alright is that
most of it - like intros and emotes yes
oh just another Sombra have that emote
with the plane with widow alright so
yeah I remember them now so we got the
marionette she controls him okay
somebody told me it's the update is up
for console and ps4 thank you a fake
flake together mercy she's a little
parasol
nice tracer has one okay so what they
lacked in skins
they got back in with a bomb
oh yeah it was she drops it nailed it
who else was there who they show fashion
highlight intros what I'm being told
okay take a look at Ginji has one right
here think of the whirlwind yeah it's
new yeah what was that last day I
remember the show that said dude okay I
think that's a new yeah yeah that's
pretty good
Kenji has an email we did that yep we
did a new scan yep
all right you want to play a game yes
let's go play a game all right there was
somebody is there actually a theme park
yeah oh you mean like in real life no I
wish dude I blazed Khan I was joking
with uh with Justin hey Wald and I told
him dude
if blizzard ever open a theme park like
I would be ruined
you would be ruined yeah because in the
sense that like I would go to it and
spend money at okay true yeah the sense
that like my girlfriend really loves
Disneyland I mean I like Disneyland but
not as much as she does right yeah and
so we probably go she likes to go at
leat try to go at least once a year
you're gonna go next month actually
and so like man if there was like a
blizzard world I'd be like babe we gotta
go to Blizzard world if you get
Disneyland I get Blizzard little dude I
would come here this it's awesome like I
don't know if you guys have seen this
map it's kind of been on PTR and things
like that but just like how reminiscent
of a theme park it is and like like I
don't know I could see these rides being
a thing you know just like that's
awesome just like little touches like
here is a store right here you can see
all the Blizzard world packaging back
here there's also like what those always
like a little like directional stands
where they have like they tell you where
stuff is like that's just so reminiscent
of like a theme park like hey come to
the heroes arcade oh [ __ ] you got that
hot our core food death wings all right
let's go let's go back to thee I wish
there was a big park though
I mean I know I wouldn't it when they
first announced it and they started
talking about like theme parks and
everything like oh god wouldn't land as
like the hook after Nova there are a
thousand credits which is not bad at all
to be honest I mean they're the same
cost as all the other legendaries are
not event priced they're just in normal
loot boxes now so hopefully you had a
bunch of you know credit saved up Joey
has like ten thousand so good buy them
all goodbye like a whole bunch right now
cz this this is so awesome like this is
like this poster right here yeah this is
exactly what you would you know if you
had a brochure and you're walking around
you're like alright where am I gonna go
first where do we gotta use our Fast
Pass floor Joey well the map itself it
goes along this route right here it goes
up to the the front of the council then
makes a rest the Main Street it's just a
mean so it does it doesn't go through
like all unfortunately you don't get to
see like Blackrock Mountain up close or
anything not yet Joey yeah wait till it
becomes really good do a real thing
bathrooms right here I've got to go to
the merlok bathrooms just exploring
protip if you ever go to Disneyland and
you're gonna go both sides California
Adventure and like me mean Disneyland
side I would say the ten dollars it
costs to get the max past Max pass it's
actually well worth it because you can
actually fast pass on your mobile phone
from like the other side of the park so
if you're like you know at California
venture and
you know you know maybe you're on
screaming it's not gonna be screaming
anymore but you're at you're at
screaming you can also then fast pass oh
oh
spaghetti oh I just get going I'll dip
that I'll dip out real quick Mike Mike
also deseed and came back in so
wonderful we can get back into surprise
it's it's just like you know any other
theme park
the ride is currently right his growth
here maintenance and we have to wait and
we apologize for the inconvenience
inconvenience yeah it did like another
update it looks like well this is the
current still doing maintenance ok we're
going back in hopefully there's no queue
or maybe we are stuck in line again who
knows we're in queue this is really like
a themed ride or a theme park just
waiting for a ride yeah anyways back to
my max pass thing yeah you should it's
totally worth the $10 as long as you're
you know like you've purchased a hopper
you know if you don't buy the hopper
it's probably not worth it I mean yeah
the advantage of being able to reserve
something all the way on the other side
of the park while you're in line for
something else yeah really nice it's
very convenient saves you like from
having to walk because that distance is
over miles is a long distance to cover
some time so yeah you got to be
strategic all right this is going this
is going pretty quick don't you realize
I'm like alright fur also for all those
asking about skins we just looked at
pretty much all of them if you scrub
back in the player you'll be able to see
all those skins I'm guessing a lot of
people that either got kicked out or
whatever also in queue so probably maybe
struggle to get in as it normally is you
know we need oh you know what we need
the stupid Disneyland game that you put
on your head yeah we I do heads up so if
we got kicked again
maybe I ya know hey we're
a theme-park experience right let me
need a churro I need five of them oh man
don't tell me about talk to me about
churros when when my girlfriend gets
gets hangry or it gets upset at the park
the easiest way is here's a chair oh
babe and and then it just comes calm to
death that's probably what I'm gonna
have to do with like when you have kids
is you just had to bribe them and get
them like if going to Disneyland wasn't
enough you still got to give them like
ice cream or something
heads up oh so just or we can play heads
up with the chat that's that's awesome
to them yeah all 30-second delay though
there's 30 seconds thought well twitch
will get it a little bit quicker
heads up free app hopefully I have
enough space on my phone damn I should
have thought about this I should have
saw this coming like we would literally
have the weight of mine and we would
have to play heads up luckily it's not a
very big app I don't think I never knew
it was a Warner Brothers application we
got some big money behind that hundred
players not bad not bad not bad not bad
might not need heads up at this point
it's installing so I'm not alone in
queue no you're not don't have a name I
was like Haven nope nope don't have a
name oh oh it's working
my head's up is working 50 there's a
Geico head get out of here oh god
there's 69 decks of in this in this my
cards here hold on alright we're
connecting entering can we please play
some Metra maybe fix the cast I just saw
your Dragonball Fighters team you guys
should definitely do it oh we're doing
another ship definitely so fun fact this
this week as Joey had told me earlier in
our like morning meetings like this is a
pretty solid week of streams not like
yeah so today we have the fun of
Blizzard Blizzard world and tomorrow
we're gonna have sea of thieves don't
tease them like that Joey go play open
one I find open open one you're like a
kid can't take you anywhere
got nothing
that's why old yeah I see you uh uh okay
another one
monster hunter world here open ten
Monster Hunter world on Thursday cfdv
okay sorry see if these tomorrow
monster hunter world Thursday I believe
and then fighters on Friday will be
doing some some real matches Joey's
probably gonna kill me because he has a
game for like a week and a half and I
pretty much just played at his desk here
and there
he's got nothing so far this is when you
actually want dupes and gold right yeah
if you don't get the skins so you got oh
also if they have a new player icons as
well like a little cute are those the
ones you're alright so no my wife didn't
work on these you were only the sprays
okay alright gold that's a quarter of a
legendary skin or you could just buy the
Reaper or the okay so these are the ones
that you were yeah that's awesome you're
at work I know I was like viewing your
wife's work I was like I've seen these
already
alright I'm one card away from heads up
guys Ellen DeGeneres is telling me
something on this heads-up I know how to
play Ellen wow there's actually a heads
up Millennials
Oh for like as a top of all the topics
yeah we got me I'm gonna be spraying
these all over the place
I'm so excited to see them like a PTR
this is just straight-up out in the wild
so if you are trying to play it's out on
pc should also be on console if you had
the the launcher open you might want to
close it and reopen it there was a queue
to get into so just have that already
have you got anything yet i've totally
not been paying the engine i got a
couple of these uh player icons but
nothing and no new skins yet Wow no
legend area it feels bad I got the
overwatch yeah
all right what do you know oh you got
one word yeah boom you got is that
purple gold at least you know oh all
right trying to play game oh you know I
want to I want to where we don't walk
off again oh my god our heads up it is
all right heads up it is we're getting
back in line boys and girls we literally
open ten boxes uh the category will be I
don't know what is this thing anything
is there all right millenials
no there isn't from let me preface this
so from are you oh it's doing another
update I wonder well no we're just
rolling them out from Ariana Grande -
Zac Efron we've packed all of your
favorite millennial celebrities into
this super fun deck those are my
favorite yet your teammates to guess
what's on the card without saying any of
the words and without rhyming Oh God
okay you can't be like sounds like blah
blah I have to do this to you and then
yeah alright so just so you guys know
I'll quickly show you that we're in a
player we're in line for the ride to get
to get into the thing so we're gonna do
what everyone does at Disneyland which
is play heads up I'm awful at this game
how do I show you guys so that's the so
you hold it up in front of yours I know
I know I know oh shoot I can't look at
that huh
but then oh how do I give it to that you
give to them don't look at the screen
hurry Internet okay so where am i
holding this up just hold over there to
the camera but don't look at it maybe
just put over your eyes or something
okay there's so many programs alright
alright this is the it's the it's the oh
my god
Kanye's sister-in-law Khloe Kardashian
there you go so you yeah I flipped it
right
no you pass you have to go down oh all
right I guess
it's past that one try to get who are
these okay past it's clear to see do it
okay I'm gonna have to keep passing
Jesus all right she was in five days of
summer with Joseph gordon-levitt oh god
I don't know that you also have she has
her own show called new girl Oh Zoey
Deschanel there you go all right she's a
Beauty and the Beast she's the new Belle
oh it's Hermione but what's her name
what's her actual name I'm terrible with
celebrity name okay that didn't go very
well
I need more healing Oh weird your
players in line so this is working guys
this is working also they were like
Jonah Hill how do you not know Jonah
Hill no you passed on them oh who are
these three people
Tinie Tempah is that a rapper probably
Kiley Boone Bray who they know Watson it
was Emma Watson I don't like this
millennial category alright alright your
turn though right what do you want here
you pick a category where 100 players we
got 100 players in front of us sorry
we're doing our best to kind of uh here
we go I like this one adult supervision
we're all adults here these saucy cars
are for the young at heart but for old
enough but old enough to buy a beer okay
I'm gonna fail at this so bad all right
I'm looking at the place state on your
forehead yep okay I'm getting ready
three two one two one uh it's something
that girls wear on their legs
garter it's something it's like a
potential fetish kind of thing it's not
maybe maybe fetish is the wrong word
it's like oh god just pass Oh Ross and
of friends who's who's Ross's main um
gym no no no Ross is a main girlfriend
that like he doesn't like they break up
multiple times but then he's he always
ends up with her just so you know I've
never watched friends are you okay mr.
and mrs. Smith the actress
Oh Angela Julie no the other oh shoot
okay Oh Brad Pitt cheated on Angelina
Jolie we knew yeah okay that's correct
down down we got nine seconds ah this
girl used to be very popular she became
a DJ and then now no one really talks
about her anymore she dated um one of
the god the Backstreet Boys guy God I
don't know all right what happened this
wasn't much Paris I thought we were 50
away yeah and then it's crash crash oh
my god all right they're terrible at
this game yeah I know
I didn't say Kelly Rowland you just said
Roland all right what's what's our Q 600
so that didn't really work it's net
stockings I don't know I didn't know God
what are these so hard why isn't there
like a more like just like very like
bland like just is there more cards you
probably have two ball there are more
cards down below our way are these free
baby shower double-decker are 500 and Q
alright well we'll do this again all
right we'll go we'll go back to heads-up
Disney Parks what is that start with I
know all right I would have known that
he didn't watch friends how could I do
anything about this see there's one just
literally friends I would I probably
suck at that one video game land here
we're gonna pick video game where this
one might be the princess open captions
and only you can free her navigate your
way through this land of video games and
characters both old and new oh it's 99
cents dude I must not have the normal
like heads up I must have got like a bad
version animals gone wild we're picking
that I don't know guess the animal okay
okay I got to be able to guess the
animal right we'll see all right these
things are extinct they have huge tusks
right now Oh extinct they're extinct
damn it Oh what kind of man woolly
mammoth there you go down yeah down um
these things destroy would they eat
through everything what
pecker uh their weavers tiny in summers
Oh insects that termites yeah
all right these things are there in the
in the jungle or not in the jungle of
the savanna lions tigers they leap and
frolic uh gazelles yeah all right these
things are can I say what kind of animal
it is I don't know it's okay
these are the biggest lizards in the
world iguana no Komodo dragon ooh yeah
all right this it's a baby sheep
what baby goat I don't know what uh look
at tiny oh my god I'm thinking of like
veal damn it we got a strawberry - this
is some BS man look at that sir bear it
was a Cobra a lamb lamb a little lamb
that was by far best though does we got
we got for us by far our best for we got
four all right we're trying again we'll
see how that goes
someone was asking actually real quick
about the the patch notes if oh you want
to go back to that okay boop boop um
mercy or junk rat changes are in and
does it does not look like it's only the
blues and the skins
hello coat Mary had Oh see that would
have worked
Mary had a little I would have totally
got that no hey you didn't know who
Jennifer Aniston was though you told me
not what you read mrs. Smith yeah yeah
that was a mistake the friends won it
should have worked right away for you
though all right what do you want to do
accents no accents and impressions you
think you can how about happy holidays
how can we how could we possibly screw
that up find out I don't know we're
gonna find out how we're gonna screw up
the all right we're in queue again we're
in queue hell line hill for the
Disneyland ride while we play heads up
here there's who won oh it's a song dun
dun dun dun dun
there are you love to sing I don't know
alright then skip it
skip it I don't know how that works how
what the hell is this category skip it
uh
blank Christmas white know whatever yep
that down Oh what did you just say
Christmas but the word before that white
yep say the whole thing now wait
Christmas yep down we would yeah I don't
know
Oh Macaulay Culkin alone yep go uh what
do we have to buy for game of the year
what kind of things did we ask you to
wear oh my ugly sweaters yes
well close enough how do I mean yes yes
something and well how else am I
supposed to describe that to you how
else are you supposed to do songs when
oh that that made of like fireworks
noise well we got five on that yeah like
how else are you supposed to do a song
name where it were a hundred and Q now
we're getting closer by playing heads up
how else are you supposed to do it like
that's a song name yeah that's why I was
doing like rocking around the Christmas
tree and happy oh I don't even think
those are the right lyrics but humming
is definitely cheating but how do you
how do you describe a song like the what
the title is you're like yeah but how do
i how do i how do I even say any of the
words without you do I say the other
lyrics of the songs I don't know the
Nerf report says humming is allowed I
will allow you still have to guess the
song I think you should sing it but I
can't sing it without saying the words
so then all right we're in I can't do
the video game category because I got a
pain 99 cents for it buy it for the
stream okay well if we keep getting
stuck don't do loop boxes to play the
game if we keep having a wait in line
then yes I will gladly plug maybe pay a
dollar to get video game heads up I
guess what I need to check is if there's
another version of heads up that I don't
have because there's there's there's
definitely like a Disneyland version
right like something that's like oh
there's a red
heerd heads up that's five stars oh but
it's it's only got like one review on it
alright let's go alright back to the
game we finally made it to the theme
park after several crashes and several
games of heads up some that were good
and somewhere that were bad but hey we
made it
so some Moira I just got kicked from
winning a competitive game for this
stupid update and I've been kicked from
the game several times yeah so I think
noob toe - I think like it's weird it's
almost like the game is like constantly
updating yeah they say with little
patches so according to the the launch
they said they're doing live it's
probably said like a couple times that's
why we got heads up guys
I gotta find a new heads up after though
let me look in the apps the entrance to
Blizzard world right over there
we're so close this this the hearts this
is the hearthstone tavern I think dude I
could use beer right now after all these
crashes Real Talk
a little hearthstone uh like a hot toddy
or something a little boards right here
Corona coach I'm saying might as well
wait another hour nah man it's it's like
the the grand opening of Blizzard world
or Blizz world how do we not want to
just like like if you guys know your
Disneyland history you'll know that what
Sun was what Black Friday I think or
black Sunday was the first weekend that
Disneyland open and it was a disaster
like there was none of food for people
lines were way too long kind of like oh
this is gonna be alright we're kind of
playing the game now which is all right
while I look for a heads up gay I feel
like it heads up
no come back get into position
so yeah for all those wandering the
skins we showed in the beginning of the
stream so go back there if you want to
see it I'm sure there's gonna be a
gallery on day spot - but we're gonna
enjoy a kind of exploring blizzard world
while trying to avoid an actual game
diva get back here oh great all right
that [ __ ] is so much wearing no oh this
is some Metra she probably put a bunch
of turrets on that other side of it
kiss my health bar there's guess it
social charades game I don't a razor all
right I'm gonna have to Google this how
did you get in with a lot of luck a lot
of patience oh my good
Cup games those couple games are heads
up heads up helped a lot now it's
probably a lot harder to play heads up
if you're by yourself though go in line
no no yeah you got a heal your team
needs healing we go here's playing
pretty pretty legit looks like a lot of
people buy the new scans at school
Reinhard
he's got young Reinhart right Bert no
can't tell how looks like gun Reinhardt
right no or is that the older that's the
old ass right hi
that's boring oh my god snuck up on me
more her deeps
according to Nattie oh five he's got six
teeth that he or she's got sixty
thousand players ahead of them
sixty thousand I that's crazy PC uh do
you did we play this on PTR no but I
played this at Blizzcon it's pretty cool
but the problem was it came out all you
guys are oh you're still out I got the
somewhat blocked that's a good spot
everyone was playing war at the time so
it's like tough mario cap 500 at
GameSpot might need to get a mod we got
mods don't worry they're they're about
in the office I'm in queue for the
eighth time yeah we're in queue a couple
a good amount of times there but you
know when luckily I have Joey here we
can and you guys and gals we can
actually play heads up really do I do
have the right game but I might just
have to buy all right if it goes I'll
have to buy some packs oh there's a nova
Widowmaker
you best where's your cloaking huh why
can't you clog I almost got her cause
your dancer why can't you cloak if your
Nova
Oh
in the Otacon or else oh that's not good
oh she got rest huh I thought you killed
there okay snipe dice I don't know what
that guy's good oh oh I'm good are you
though okay nice plane is like God yeah
you better be on one of those who's got
the better beam was Blizzcon lit yeah
blitz cosplay lit I kind of wish there
was a Diablo announcement personally I
was I was trying to do but uh nothing
nothing doing this year maybe next year
you got a ball it's just you a mercy and
oh they're all here you all want you
just got your uh your paid back what
character is he playing he's playing war
right now
alright let's go turn that beat up no
well lost our first match at blues world
feels bad man hey jet dude from the park
so you get for being a bad children that
kid it's white like a turd kill 100
percent
the map is out the dank stuffs a good
seems like there's have been rolling
kind of like rolling updates live
updating so just be mindful that you
might get kicked in the process which
happened to us but all good we're back
in there and I'm gonna look at buying um
don't speak too soon oh my god I didn't
even I was just about to say I'm about
to buy something for heads up I like how
he kicks us right after we kick this
after the match that was kind of them so
uh sorry I'm looking for the heads up
app I don't know it's not where the hell
is my head oh there it is here's on the
last page alright hold on let me you
just want your first match at blues
world did you get any route like tickets
all right here we'll just do no there's
no queue in the trick-or-treat maybe
what you think Trick or Treat trick or
treat yeah a trick or treat you game
happy Halloween trick or treat yourself
to some spooky fun with this
limited-time deck guess the word without
saying anything on the card and without
rhyming see you can hum the song it's
fine alright here we go
because clearly was it mean I did this
or whatever we'll do it this way
alright it's what it's the initials when
someone die P yeah the what it's it's
big scary
Jason Freddie no the actual item on like
the Cookie Monster what you would call
those things there are what goes these
trolls pass that work it's not a wizard
but like a lady who writes like a mystic
witch yeah what's okay go by your head
the the doctor who made that gonna hide
the big freaking yeah yeah yes
I don't understand why these are mixed
in here it's the guy with the horse and
Sleepy Hollow yeah what's his name hey
let's horsemen damnit for we got four
you need to look at why okay you work on
the queue I will such entertainment yeah
we're trying guys are the servers are
Nicki Minaj
you could've did like a princess well
why is she in this category it might
just be people that like you dress up as
Halloween scary people Nicki Minaj would
have been like what would I have done I
don't know what I would have done there
would have been like try to find a song
truffle butter you know princess
princess you could've just said peach
what is peach princess pile I was just I
was just like confused as to I thought
they were that way we're in a thousand
player key I'm gonna try Halloween I'm
gonna probably suck at it but here we go
alright just to show you we have a
thousand people on queue so we're
playing we're in line so we're playing
heads up what do people do together so
during Halloween they dress up and they
go to these things trick-or-treat
parties yeah but the what kind of party
Halloween party got a pass that I said
what kind of party
damnit in the what is like when there's
light hitting you there's there's like a
dark darkness on the ground what do ya
okay what is a t-rex is a dinosaur okay
a which rides on a room yep if you
jumped off a cliff you would be dead
know what what's the act of suicidal no
like as you're going down you are no
velocity yeah yeah it's fine
when kids put poop in a bag and they
leave it at the doorstep damn it's
afraid yes that was correct we're still
a thousand five maybe six yeah you got
five so I
think that I think that I'm better at
doing the wording sans the Jennifer
Aniston Anna stirred thing and you're
better at guessing
alright we're still in a thousand here
I'll show you guys I wear thought so
we're gonna pick another category here
let me buy the gaming one god damn it
you got me heads up you got me because
I've over watch my video game land how
do i how do I buy this do it is my
account even linked none of these
hopefully that's still my visa this is
for you guys in the stream all payments
successful yes I'm gonna restart the
launcher real quick okay why weren't you
in a thousand and Q yeah but it did move
it was so early oh my god you were
horrible at this game oh no man oh shoot
alright uh in the game with rapture
Bioshock yeah the one where you try to
swing but to swing in ropes and try not
to fall into pits flunky I just
basically this game is never coming out
has Sora goofy Donald Kingdom Hearts 3
yeah another Caped Crusader Batman it's
the dog and rabbit point-and-click
adventure Oh God
talking rabbit they're detectives and is
it Nick loves this it's hand to egg
football yeah whatever the Pro Skater
craze was started by whom Tony Hawk yeah
this one is with the by naughty dog they
charted the other one last time
damn it we're gonna do it we're gonna
run it back Sam and Max's adventure
football it was a 5 though that's like
is that aerobatic that's a record 5 is
our best I was just
okay we're gonna do gate I've literally
bought that for 99 cents I don't want to
watch a video they still have to make
you know this so for season haven't
watch me but get out of here oh what's
that was that free now was it free yes I
literally bought the video game land for
$1 so we're gonna make use of this Oh
hit thing I got the update but it seems
like they're also doing - yeah they're
kind of like doing like on and off
maintenance alright three two one
Ubisoft game that's about to come out in
March we're like yep not quake but it's
like oh yeah but what are yep mm-hmm
Zelda uses this in breath of the wild
it's the thing you get from the forest
the Master Sword yeah mm-hmm skip that
one I don't know how to describe that
one
it's the IO Interactive game they broke
off from square to make man yep oh god
how do I skip it
Luke uses this as a weapon saber yep
it's an iconic half no it's an iconic
steam game it's not half life but Team
Fortress know the other one there's only
two of them you made it you made us yeah
and then it's the weapon so it's a
portal gun yep uh Dante's Inferno I
didn't know how to do Qbert either like
what cut the rope like I kinda I was
just like oh six got six okay turns out
video games is our ally who wouldn't you
we're still a thousand and Q I'll just
play the video game one again damn he's
good
we were losing meters but that's fine
we're going back to people say the the
EU servers are better yeah but we don't
have anything right can you get on EU oh
I probably give it a go ping would
probably be really bad fine you would be
like a hundred painting we can try LML
Oh lmao just got in and it kicked me out
with three thousand ahead yeah it seems
about right the homeless character in
wreck-it Ralph is Dante's and no Qbert
Oh Qbert yeah but I dude I'd I was not
coming me it was easier to just pass and
then get one right five that how is this
better it's 5,000 in queue and EU y'all
be trolling maybe Asia no just kidding
I've that's live maintenance for you
grand opening overwatch can't connect to
servers and when you get in game is
still disconnect you hey it is literally
like what would happen at a new theme
park the rides break that's why you got
have no like that's why you have games
like heads up Oh God all right he's gone
of war Kratos
yeah not not Samus is in there veteran
I'm her second adventure for Super
Nintendo Super Metroid yeah he one runs
on walls he can rewind time I don't see
the sands of time Oh Prince of Persia
yeah
alright big cowboy game coming out
pretty soon right there redemption yeah
you drive on motorbikes it's the old NES
game Excitebike yeah this is something
that you slip on ice a food that you
people Nana leave yeah banana peel yeah
it's what baby time to kick ass what
people say forget Oh Marvel no wins
link oh no I guess we're both I wasn't
thinking of that one my god six again we
gotta beat that almost have it I I feel
like this cue is broken though we're a
thousand players ahead of us although
you know I think we cheated on the bike
one cuz you said bike yeah we are
playing heads up it is a game that a lot
of people play when they're in a theme
park mainly Disneyland and yeah I mean
we're doing what you would do if you're
in line so we're literally in line
waiting to play a game so here we go oh
you guys just got hit back and then you
got to do the thing and I do the I do
the the hints and you do the guessing
it's what baby
it's Marvel but it's supposed to be wins
I don't know Chris are you finding this
entertaining well that would be this is
the best I can do alright here we go
the queue is not moving just so you guys
know alright here we go
oh you broke it way to go into my
messages three two one it's one of those
yellow things we have in the studio
there's a yellow red it's a Nintendo
game they're small they kind of add up
together to like become something bigger
to do stuff wait what yellow they're
like little creatures that they like
form together to do stuff informers know
it's an instant skip it skip it a blank
between worlds link yep it was an old EA
game where you control a bunch of
different people you'd also build their
houses tell them what to do yeah but
what is it's your building buildings so
think of that work yep mm-hmm
it's a pink guy in Smash correct yep ice
who does trip Mario try to save Princess
Peach yep
go down
is that from [ __ ] it ah we're still a
thousand in minkyu if you guys are
curious yeah that's what they are right
like they're colored yeah and they kind
of like combine robots in disguise oh
and a okay yeah hallo weapon that's what
it was sorry what was it oh and energy
sword I just like the last ten seconds I
just like brain farting alright I'll try
that again so far so far there's been at
least non-duplicate questions what can
we ask for at this point I here we go
yeah I'm sorry guys hallo alright it's
the the big Japanese RPG not for fancy
but Chrono Cross no no mana the other
bit long-running series I'm gonna look
like a noob for that one
alright oh this is a mobile game where
you fly as a bird
Oh Angry Bird Angry Birds Oh flappy duck
oh it's the one where you skip it it's
one of the big MOBAs Korea Legends dota
yeah oh damn it I saw it FIFA it's haha
we get one back the the main the main
human the StarCraft Jim Raynor yeah
alright the the oldest video one of the
oldest video games is just back and
forth pong yeah this is the the Naughty
Dog series I charted yeah more it's the
Metroid lady 7 yeah
infamous infamous I think we got six ago
okay break6 Dragon Quest oh my god well
dota you would have gotten you guys I
did yeah but I cheated oh wait I didn't
get Yukio oh that was like as you were
oh man I wish I could have got that it's
time to do would you have got that I
know or what if I said X Odia blue-eyes
White Dragon blue-eyes White Dragon oh
okay only thing I know still a thousand
in line so we're gonna I guess it's your
turn to put it on so we got six oh we
didn't technically get six cuz we can
get you go I hate this I'm sorry
Gabrielle Batista there's not much I can
do I'm we're still waiting thousand do
we know the way
no I don't know the way this is
something you do in like MMORPGs grind
no keep going missions that you get from
people yep um he's the famous character
from half-life Gordon Freeman yep go
down again yep the main character of ff7
cloud a full name game enough yes that's
fine fine these rocks come out of the
sky and you need to shoot them it's like
an old arcade yeah yeah the main
character Tomb Raider Lara Croft yep
Laura blank breath of the wild Zelda yep
this game is about to come out fighting
game with swords Cervantes
yep the driving game on Nintendo that's
very popular with art yeah but on Blake
NES the yeah Super Mario Kart super Beck
Beck snake that was seven right yeah
yeah we nailed the first seven there
feels good
but this queue feels awful because okay
the ride has literally broke they said
so
we're in the position where they do not
know when the ride will be fixed yes
exactly so
is when you uh when you get to the front
of the line you complaining to the
Disney folks and say hey this is a bad
experience and then they actually
sometimes give you friend of the line
pass they'll give you passes for that I
don't think our case I'm hoping for some
credits for winnings nothing we're not
getting nothing let's be real here the
roller coaster but we guys we have you
guys in chat and we have heads up but
yeah what does the new map look like
well why does the new map look like the
games because the rides broken server
maintenance is happening the queue is
broken
someone said 300 now though 300 yeah
we're playing a game called heads-up I
purchased the video game version which
we're doing better and better at I feel
like we've we've learned the ways come
beyond the hang of it yeah I gotten the
hang of it
don't be funny is if we just took the
map at your desk and just like here's uh
here's a Blackrock Mountain yeah I mean
it's just we played one game and we
bought we were able to check out the
skins and we open 10 over 50 loot
crate's that's about it back to another
game of heads up did did you just hold
it on your head right yeah some people
are saying is going down that's getting
400 all right the last boss in Street
Fighter 2 and bison yeah it's the big
other the Dragon Quest but 5 hands yeah
it's a big strategy game that were you
last for like yes match yeah
civilization yeah you're a wizard Harry
Potter Wow okay that was really
important Freeman is in this half-life
sequel too damn it
the Sega's monitor Oh Virtua Fighter
yeah Mario's nemesis Bowser the other
one the human one Waluigi Mario yeah
similar to asteroids but instead you're
on the ground shouting Galactica Galaga
oh damn it let's get last one was dual
Joe what was it it's a tank one right
missile command
I wouldn't got that it's like an x 7 we
got to break 7 now we are playing a game
called heads-up and the reason why we're
doing that is because it's a game you
would play while you're waiting in line
at Disneyland it's like what a lot of
people play because we are literally in
line to get into the theme park that is
broken so I apologize to the people
we're just trying to entertain you guys
while we wait in line or pretty much
entertain ourselves too so I figure it's
your turn so I figure while we wait in
line we're just gonna have to play I
mean that's just kind of how it is the
old kind of vampire game side-scrolling
yep Sega Genesis big game blue thingy
sorry yep yeah yeah yeah
that one Facebook game that like a
really big one no the other big one that
a lot of older people play it's like a
match 3 game it's sweet it's like sweet
tea Oh candy crush the last song yep
the game where you jump across the
street as an animal while avoiding yep
dysentry you died a dysentry in this
game
Oh organ trail yeah that's close enough
it's the Oregon Trail well the the
stylish girl with two guns on Nintendo
it's getting remastered in a couple
months
yep Oh skip I don't what the hell is
that oh no no I knew that one double oh
seven G's one yeah
damn it Oh Shadow of the Colossus oh we
moved we moved 100 we moved 100 which
one's a which one does shadows of the
Colossus Tupac pee okay I don't know
what that is but we would have got
shadow of Colossus so he's still stuck
at seven almost no we're not
changing regions it took forever just to
move 100 mate loot boxes great again
yeah we're trying glados oh we didn't
even have that that what would you say
is shrim up one for Glatt wait which one
GLaDOS is that BIOS is a portal Oh
videogames alright here we go
how can I don't hear the countdown
alright it's a me Mario yeah mike
tyson's what punch-out yeah it's so
quiet
um the other big square RPG for the
Super Nintendo with cut across um Snake
Eater snake Metal Gear Solid one of the
other shooters not Not Call of Duty
battlefield it was around that same time
where they don't make it anymore a Medal
of Honor
yeah the kingdom of wet in Zelda Jairo
Jairo yeah Justin really likes this game
Animal Crossing yeah skip though it's
that old old-ass PC game where you make
animals just fall off ledges
those lemmings oh okay yeah play things
so long oh we almost know well you got
Chrono Trigger I don't know what stuck
at 7 this is oh we moved to another
hundred we can see it we can see the
beginning of the like a route line to
the actual ride that final room where we
turn the corner you can actually see
them boarding there we go I don't know
here maybe I should back out of the app
cuz I don't know where the audio stop
playing because the media audio is all
the way up man this is the best dollar
I've spent here you go alright ya know
what lemmings man he's to play the game
all the time in elementary
the audio is dead oh great
I already saw that one mobile game that
you were saying earlier that wasn't
candy crush saga yep mm-hmm
that game that giant bomb hates with Dan
Reicher lives loves Nintendo game party
yeah
destiny hunter solar hunter super what
what kind of dong burger okay in
double-oh-seven
on snez it's a one-shot kill in
multiplayer than good yep mm-hmm
not call of duty but battlefield yep
oh this game is coming out Friday we're
playing it edible but the last letter of
that yep hmm
not dota but League of Legends yep skip
Mario his nemesis Wario no yeah okay we
need to turn the sound back on I don't
know what's here I'll turn off my phone
and turn it back on I don't know what
did we move up in queue I don't know we
did we only got six there we would have
got seven if we got Bowser let me turn
off my phone restart no was the one
shotgun yeah so like I was trying to do
so Golden Gun is a super yeah I just
don't I just yeah I should have just
went with I thought that will ascend
first but then you know me destiny
anytime anyway I can slip in the destiny
be prepared to wait nearly an hour
really we were in earlier someone said
andropause Andre pause said that after a
thousand people he got in but then he
got kicked if we got kicked again I'll
probably call it a stream because that's
just really crappy and I don't want you
guys to you guys are already enduring as
good as you are here hopefully you're
having fun so Lee Lee win Godwin the
reason why he said Wario was because
Wario was actually an answer
oh we moved up 100 Wario was actually an
answer earlier because I said Bowser and
he was like no not there but older one
and Sterling Barrett just got in that's
for getting in I guess he's not really
his Nemus
this I mean I understood I understand
it's just like the hint right like you
just need the hint since days did they
mention the the backstory behind Wario
he was like jealous of Mario's success
Mario and Luigi success or something
sure
it's all about why Luigi though ps4 has
no queue at all really yeah we got we're
down to 700 wait why can't okay let's
see if the audio works now
the queue is so long I know right just
like a theme park just like a real theme
park favorite new skin ask Braxton bent
dude I gotta go for me road hog butcher
was legit I really liked the ERISA one
that's probably one of my favorites but
it's like pretty similar I just like the
detail of the butcher because like the
mask of the butcher the actual butcher's
cleaver the fresh meat on his like with
uh with the like apron
yeah that's legit I was a old school
Diablo fan ACG says that's why he likes
the butcher skin yeah alright we're
we're still waiting in line was it me
are you oh okay okay we got sound all
right it's not Ken but Ryu yeah the for
the DS you could play with little
animals on your Pokemon oh that dog
stupid game I forget it go get oh it's
not passing okay um he's a wrestler he
was on the go game brother Oh Kane yeah
you see here the Capcom game where you
play that kid who turns to a superhero
yes and then you fight like infamous Ede
skip that first-person adventure game
from like 94 something where you're on
an island and you just solve puzzles I'm
real bad at this right now David cage
heavy rain yeah
the dizzy already sky damn it god I'm
sorry chat I failed us so bad that time
beautiful Joe beautiful Joe Disney's
infinity that company that went out of
business
rest in peace there you go well 600
we've moved up a little bit like ever so
slightly I hope we don't get kicked like
that other prison did that would be
unfortunate and I need a churro for sure
blah blah blah mankind it was a square
Enix game skip it
I [ __ ] it was deus ex skip it uh it's
not kotor oh [ __ ] skip it I gotta [ __ ]
it up I said kotor not rock band but a
similar type of game our hero yeah
oh god he's a purple purple creature on
the playstation I call him a creature
because I can't buy ro yeah what the
dragon yeah yeah yeah okay
clouds nemesis who stabs Aerith
Sephiroth yep
ken Ryu on the Super Nintendo Street
Fighter 2 yeah the green animal in that
game Blanca
yeah cloaked unit in Starcraft
which one was it banshee Deus Ex mankind
is it mankind Deus Ex mankind mankind
divided fudge
alright we got five on that one we're
starting to crumble here we're starting
to get worse thought we were getting
better
oops almost worked at four come on I
just won't play overwatch yeah we do too
alright the Skyrim series is called what
Elder Scrolls yeah
this is a big world war two game this
year called danger yeah
the dinosaur hunter Tarak yeah he's a
web slinger Spider Man yet this is a ps1
game
abe's oddysee do you know what about it
oh I don't know I forget I forget it
that's fine
the Nintendo's biggest console the
motion controls a Wii yeah Kratos is the
God of War yeah
parkour running free running red nears
edge yeah come on phone we're killing it
The Legend of Zelda the breath of the
wild n64 version Ocarina of Time Wind
Waker not Mario's this is some [ __ ]
this is some I think some phone lag
right here I we were on a damn roll odd
world dang it eight eight eight you
still need to get all ten oh we got
weird over 500 okay so yeah literally
we're crawling I just want to show you
that we're waiting okay like this is
just how it is
I want Blizzard world in real life says
Roxanna Khobar I agree I would love that
that would be awesome
does ps4 work some people said yes some
people say no so I don't know
I think the live stream is okay they
can't do anything about it thank you
caroll rocks alright time to play says
JT batista later see you hopefully you
don't get kicked right away like some
other people were saying you're flicking
the wrists too hard says pública may be
gentle oh yeah we're waiting in queue
man scout gating gaming and doing what
we would do if we were at Disneyland
playing heads up
mobile game it's time to kick ass and
chew bubblegum who is that John Cena my
place I think John Cena I don't know you
come all right
what does ryu and ken do both Hadouken
yeah uh Terry Bogard King of Fighters ya
know the before that uh what was joe
higashi it's a fighting game the art of
fighting know if it's kiss kiss kiss it
was fatal fury not read that Redemption
but the game the other big rock star
game
Oh GTA Grand Theft Auto yeah RTS game
Koreans are really good at a blizzard
game yep it's a PlayStation game there's
an animal there's a human there they go
they played that you need both of you
yes yes
god I was terrible the mobile game where
you cut up stuff yeah that's right
great stream when I'm bored I'm already
playing Blizzard but I'm still watching
you to see supper thank you I guess
that's better than nothing Gani Mead
says my favorite skin is road hog
Theresa yeah once you guys shout out
your guys's favorite skins from this
batch of skins I guess well we play
unfortunately they did not make a Ginji
legendary for this one yeah he has an
emote we are 500 players in the queue
still so we're playing a mobile game
called heads up as I mentioned it's to
try to simulate what it would be like if
we were at Disneyland so here we go the
ride is essentially broken right now all
right we got um the other mm oh that's
not Wow but it's like free to play every
quest one of the bigger ones
Oh Guild Wars yeah um Dante inferno DMC
Devil May Cry
uh blink his game blink his link link
Ozel de yeah halos protagonist is master
chief yes pass um you you got I got my
shiny what card and Pokemon
Charizard yeah Oh pass you ride him in
Super Mario World Yoshi yeah the wife of
the can't say his name damn it
the female version of this arcade game
man
oh you could have just been like that
yellow thing that eats stuff but not him
his counterpart come on we got six that
was not bad Zuma I don't know a contra
what is the s in contra spread going see
I think you're better at guessing and
I'm better at dropping hints as long as
I know the game we are four hundred we
are we're making it slowly but surely
we're making it yeah we are on PC right
now Ganymede place on your forehead out
of focus because it's focused on us not
on manual that fighting game on Nintendo
that's really big it's on the n64 nope
super Spanish mode yes mm-hmm
not scorpion but sub-zero yep
Skyrim is part of this world as you had
mentioned but this is a specific one
online no just skip it that once I don't
know how to describe that one to you not
h1z1 but Daisy yep a DS game where oh my
gosh how do I beat a make food cookie
mama yep
this is a mobile game where you send
somebody a picture that you did yourself
and don't have the guesses close draw
anything close another word for anything
something yeah Daisy in 2018 yeah we're
currently playing heads up as whirring
queue here what do we get there yeah I
would love there to be another one
someday it's a setting that he gets ESL
before morrowind I wouldn't have got
that one either you know different
people play different games epidemics so
it's kind of just what happens still 400
players in line all right here we go all
right oh there's a second all right a
little mushroom guy in Mario toad yeah
we were just talking about this the the
gun that you can go into alcohol yeah he
blows stuff up he walks on the bomber
man yeah the spinning bird kick lady
mystery vehicles that you drive around
in these series in USA you just drive
around in these cars yeah you block this
is a bunch of lies no two blocks so you
fit into things and they disappear yeah
you just said this the fatal fury guy
Terry Bogard yeah
the mean that the main bad guy and Zelda
all the Zelda games Ganon yeah
all right this this lady has a bunch of
hair that turns into a stone Maura don't
buy that snake hair Medusa oh that
number 10 I don't know it felt good it
felt good
no like an eight are you okay buster
will write 300 oh nice nice see here see
you tell you man
sup works I don't know where cars came
from that's I mean there is a cars game
I guess so
ciao I might have got that I don't know
I don't know when it's gonna be in
Russia sorry alright uh the big shooter
from last year and also from like ninety
I don't field duty no just you just
punch demons and you ripped them apart
and shoot them oh my god oh my cry
no the other one we're on Mars Oh
destiny no casket halo the hell you play
instruments in this rock band yeah
the that one rock star game from a while
ago where you slow down boy Oh Max Payne
yeah um we're blizzard I mean we're a
World of Warcraft is the name of the
world Azeroth yeah you your your little
frogs that beat stuff up Battletoads
yeah um that that grid shooter from like
the 80s where you just contra things in
the aliens Galaga the other one ash
invaders yeah [ __ ] I mean F you're gonna
the first one doom doom that's two years
ago oh it was right Oh me was that last
year there's two years ago but that's
fair
what year is it Oh two hundred two
hundred yeah it feels good feels good
feel good come on don't screw us we're
almost at the front of the line Blizzard
I swear you're right better work by the
time we get in mortal kombat the
lightning God read it yep that Super
Nintendo game with James Bond but James
Bond yeah super sorry n64 Oh Goldeneye
double star cast main characters love
interest who turns into a Zerg
yep Lara Croft is in what game Tomb
Raider yeah a mobile game where you
fling these things at pigs
Angry Birds yep
everything is awesome lego movie legos
yeah yeah those brown things that you
jump on in Super Mario goombas yep that
same game is called Super Mario Brothers
yep
finish him fatality no more comment yep
that orange guy on PlayStation he's on
our stage last year he's a big dude that
critic yeah that was such a good run
that was the towers a good run that was
a good run we got 2 9 there's a solid
run do you think we can get the last one
before the queues oh yeah we just moved
up another 100 I think I think for us to
do that we got to do we got a this is
this is the winning combo I think this
is the winning combo me just well we got
oh we got to have a good run though
we'll see that one game on xbox 360 that
was a big game there's now four of them
nope shooter halo a third-person shooter
where you can change it all guys yep
the gun the game were the spread guns in
Contra yep
skip it oh that was a freaking car game
wasn't it
new Vegas is yeah but uh keep naming the
different numbers of a fallout 4 no
three yep this game Andromeda but the
other mm-hmm Oh God skip it cuz I can't
describe it to you we're gonna lose the
main character of Gears of War yeah
that's it we have four seconds as a bad
run the bad run
I think he's the main character right
all right well I'll try it I'll try one
well gain as many heads up games
we're like literally at the like right
behind the people that you like turn
like how many people do you have for
this ride we have to we have to 90 I
think we can do this all right it's the
mario pass or to set it dang it
um you pick people off for dreamcast you
pick people up and deposit them around
the city you drive really weird drive
really you know Mike's favorite game he
played the whole series with Mary
resonable yeah
Sammis again that's right yeah Super
Metroid um the GTA game were it's just
crazier and you can fly and you become
pretty much become a superhero at some
point you whack people with a dildo oh
that's the one yeah the the platformer
with rares new super nintendo platformer
i can't say his name monkeys donkey kong
yeah don't come what oh is it dirty we
would love to show the skins we are
almost in the game
Oh Crazy Taxi so I was like how do I
describe how you how you driving create
a duck for dr. Mario I I said Mario I
would be like Tetris with an intent no
actually that 10 players we are we have
enough players I'm not gonna entering
game ok please
what do you want open the boxes just
play the game what do you wanna do they
over the couple boxes all right I want
to get at least one skin to use in the
game could buy one just go quick okay
okay we ain't got time for that okay I
remember the guy in last time told me
just open it with spacebar alright
over the sprays yeah oh my god I just
had to he didn't do the other one
spacebar as the way to go here is that
gonna save us
we tried looking at another server
ChaCha 14 chopped 14 but Europe actually
had 5,000 people in front so that's
actually worse than na Mathis 2201 says
of each other Genji mo we showed all the
emotes and skins earlier so if you want
to check that out it's at the beginning
of the stream I would wait it out though
because we finally got in after waiting
from the thousand it just took a little
bit of time probably closer to half an
hour we probably played like half an
hour of thing heads up just FYI those
boxes are predetermined you won't get
new content but we're getting the skins
there the sprays right we are so how
will the skins be in there old boxes
don't have new stuff well that's
disappointing
if that is true but then why would the
sprays be in there then I guess they
want no I think you have to buy it with
coins can you only buy with coins
maybe well that's the case I'm gonna go
buy the one that I want right now I
think that Joey either away one today
because he was able to to get 50 boxes
oh yeah Thank You Steven sting
I'm guessing okay so you guys are all
saying you don't get new things from the
old boxes but we definitely are getting
some new things however if you're saying
specifically skins and emotes then
that's fair but we are definitely
getting the new sprays that is a hundred
percent of fact so we have not gotten a
skin that is for damn sure
but yeah we bought them after the update
so just saying alright
Divac Oh doofus okay the black hand oh
yeah all right no you can't get new
stuff in the loot boxes okay
like come on chat I mean stuff as in
like skins the yellows the the be more
specific player icons right here that's
I picked that one out from the boxes
alright I want you to play game now that
you have some skins okay yes we bought
them after the update 6 1 1 4 JN we
bought them after we updated for sure
100% sprays any most you can get easily
yes we understand that but the the
sprays that he's getting are the newer
ones literally the ones his wife made
for Blizzard she was hired to make them
just so you know if it's after the
update
you're good thank you Thank You lawful
lawful Hank sorry man I was having a lot
of fun plane uh that's a maybe we should
play heads up while we're in cute I
think we should do that I don't know if
you guys can swear the sprays oh yeah ok
it's the the hack and slash game that we
just went to go make I the one that's
just like super repetitive just over and
over dynasty worries yeah the four
player a co-op zombie game left for dead
yeah um in Wonderland Alice in
Wonderland Alice yeah Alice's a game
this one I don't know and we're starting
over in a map oh it's that pock one
again what is puck I don't know
Assad Minh Anh wants to know what you
guys main well who do you mean Joey um
really depends like if I'm playing a
tank usually I go like I like tanking a
lot usually goes Aria or IRISA yeah to
my favorites right now I've been playing
a lot of McCree and uh Genji just trying
to get a hang of them because never
really played them a lot early on emote
um okay can be Joey uh ye here Joey's
wife
Joey his wife actually made the sprays
so those little cute cutesy sprays that
you guys see or I had that one is one of
them she actually drew those and made
them for Blizzard so that's for
Christian too so basically yes his wife
is an artist and she was asked to make
do you know if they're just sprays or
are they for anything else as far as I
know they are they use Brittany yeah
they're just sprays okay just brace okay
so yeah so the sprays you see the new
sprays from this update that you see
were made by his wife right there that
one still skirmishing come on yeah also
if you guys were in line just make sure
to just be patient because we eventually
got in so hopefully you explore a little
bit oh we're just going in kobe momochi
says I miss left for dead whoa
interestingly enough I don't know how
good it's gonna be but there's that new
zombie co-op game gtfo get the F out
which looks kind of interesting it's
pretty much like kind of like in the
same vein yeah just looks a lot like
it's just like today's version of that I
yeah actually I actually played I booted
up left for dead like a couple weeks ago
just to play like a match mm-hmm still
pretty fun yeah
there's fun watching them do the
speedrun to you all right so we got that
Arista skin yeah what's up stabber
hammered off thank you for tuning in
thanks everyone for being patient with
us as we all collectively waited in line
to get into the theme park sir Zambia
the good doom fist skin oh this is so
good I like the song it's just his
shoulders so big if I have a thousand
gold I'll probably go by that oh is that
the butcher I know that was just the
walrus whoops
there's no logging problems asked to end
gaming kind of it took us a bit of time
to get through the queue but we're in
and hopefully playing hopefully we can
play at least a couple matches and then
we'll probably all in a stream again
thank you guys all for your patience
naxxramas right naxxramas next right
besides the little food mart right here
the food court serving a pretty normal
food pretty normal and snacks are amis
got some purple jelly though a turkey
leg or whatever those got some kegs
you need to have kegs so here's like the
entrance to one of the rides that's
where we were just now this one I think
it's like the like a mine train there's
an overlord gonna be awesome
fight to duskwood yeah so I as slow as
old-school Wow flight paths we're gotta
learn the fan order I wonder if there
any other ways around this joke well I
heard it oh I heard a Winston we leave
somewhere
Nick Joseph loving the map yeah it's
pretty cool
all right kind of wish there's a real
Blizzard world that'd be awesome blows
world later anime fan one seven six five
five thanks for stopping by and we'll
try our best have fun should also be on
the consoles tjm there are some
potential login delays just because I
think everyone's trying to get on and
also they were kind of doing like
rolling maintenance we're hoping that
it's stable enough where we can stay in
the game play a few matches also if
you're in queue as some people already
are in chat make sure to try to stay in
the queue because he's probably gonna
get bumped to the back of the line
if you leave so oh no hey look it's Nova
and she snapped you oh wait
no no I know but was she actually Nova
Ohio no and see why you guys are getting
rekt yep it's okay we get to see more of
the map crawls all those in your we get
to see more little you know now the
payload section starts here nice it's a
hybrid now
just died there is no queue for Xbox or
ps4 why is there a queue usually on PC
there's a queue because it's their way
of like kind of funneling people back in
every time there's like a new release of
an a big big update or like there's an
expansion or DLC or anything or even
like a new game launch for Blizzard
there's usually a queue as they kind of
like manage the servers whoa did not see
that say here's the yoke if you play
Reaper the new skin ass quest entropy
that's not too expensive 250 gold so
maybe the van helsing yeah Isabela
buckminster oh no the queues generally
on PC we're saying there was no queue on
a console but I couldn't confirm that
briefs inside
we're not playing on one you have all
the skins dead ask Hudson no we don't we
bought 50 boxes and we haven't gotten to
skin yet we bought the boxes after the
update so hoping that there are actually
like oh no new skins if not we're at
least getting enjoy gold to buy this
game are not sticking together oh well
it is quick play after all
yeah all right like a little control
room here when I get to one in the queue
there's an unexpected server that's
unfortunate I guess I don't I don't know
what's going on with that ROI panel
really wants to get in
whereas Ganges always shooting his
holtoff at me
meaning Hanzo great oh you guys are dead
she hacked that big help to me this is
the last part of the map right
pretty sure yep like leoric's dude this
is literally the end right here can you
play Devo with the news game there's a
bunch of skins he'd have to buy but yeah
Adam Laurie it released at 11 a.m. but a
lot of server issues at least on PC so
as well
entropy mentioned yeah there's too many
people on the server it's trying to
connect you to you know you lived
somehow oh boy where is she oh my mouse
is getting pulled okay there's a nice
little spot to go around
have you played a lot of this last
season or this season this season I
played I played a little bit did some
wine to know your ring right now I'm at
gold still got a ways to go
is it tiny odd thing this is the mercy
oh okay you've made up for it with the
punch you almost with it but that was
good that was good
draw drew the mercy into coded said PSN
servers are down oh that's unfortunate
sorry about that
Deanna may I'm in by later glad you're
in okay I'm watching the don't question
still down I've got you no no no no
can't roll you got high noon again this
thing go alright watch out oh man I got
the road hog and the Lucy oh yeah so
close push the mercy out of the way at
least
okay so oh you did it too late could I
say okay this is why you land party
people in a dank basement yeah I mean we
could have potentially just been like
hey five people out there in the office
try to load up in this queue 404
Melonhead vlogs good luck just be
patient I guess at least you have some
form of entertainment until until then
just like we had heads up LML oh that
panic hammer fan yeah you know when you
got a big monkey or whatnot chasing you
with the electrical beam sometimes it
tends to happen backside you know when
the lunar event comes out that's hard to
say Chinese New Year this year is
February 8th the week at the 18th so if
they're gonna do it like right before it
might be before that or if they're doing
it right
kind of like after the fact when um
Chinese New Year hits then it would be
what's the actual date well like for
what I know like Chinese New Year
weekend is the sixteen seventeen
eighteen nineteen nineties is a holiday
so they could either come out on the
20th which is a Tuesday or maybe the
13th before actual Chinese here okay you
got a big
market coming surprisingly holding this
is all yard spot to get through though
yeah oh oh they're all there in that way
well I have a dead eye I see also yeah
we'll see how this goes
they're not pushing it though because
the other side so just no worries melon
head vlogs thanks for stopping by
appreciate the interaction it's night
gonna cue 800 started at 2,000 yeah I
took us a while void regalia we want to
play it a lot of heads up just now kind
of what a well-placed - play of the game
if that is that's gonna be hilarious
do it anyways cook it with a saucer I'm
waiting on the queue - that's why I'm
here
welcome to anybody that's waiting in
queue welcome oh yeah watch it's that
one is it gonna be the spawn I didn't
notice
oh no Joey
is to get both is that why he stopped to
supers you go torment these in hook acts
are accuracy their next game Reaper
question mark yeah I don't win though
you'd have to back out to buy yeah scary
but then you should you have 31 boxes to
true okay you're all I'll hop into a
queue yeah but that's the thing
I don't know I don't think I have seen
one of the new skin I haven't eaten in
here I haven't either
so I'm wondering if those people that
were saying it were correct but then
everyone said after the fact like did
you buy him after the update we did so I
don't know you can make them hold off we
logged in it was what if the boxes are
bugged maybe they'll give us some new we
could put the player icons and the
sprays are in there so I don't know
yeah the Faro one sounds good I feel
like there's some bias there wants to
know if you can play widow Widow well we
got legendary of gold 500 those are one
that's enough to buy two purples that's
not okay you know just lose buy them
I'll put some more boxes then yeah
Hellfire yeah yeah and you like these
[Music]
but will you really not use this one for
a little bit and then switch back to
them okay Hudson Cordia asking do you
guys have any tips for competitive I am
in gold and 200 points off of my first
golden gun I've decided for tracer
because I have 37 hours on her and four
on widow please can you give me some
tips back racer I don't really play a
lot of tracer yeah I don't play a comp
myself so I can't really speak to that
but I mean just keep grinding really I
mean that's all you can do right like if
you like tracer maybe watch start
watching overwatch League you know like
there's a lot of tracers there now
obviously trying to mirror pro players
is not the easiest thing but you can at
least try to see just like the strategy
pick up on certain things that they do
like when to engage and like how to
manage your recall I guess is pretty
good void regalia is saying seems to
drop really fast now after a thousand
and now at fifty that's good what's up
Rob the Rob the average hi hello thank
you to the thank you for tuning into the
stream and any skin she has a
counterpart skin was in Jana yeah kind
of can you please play McCready that's
my main he just played summer Cree
Reapers my main says Harry Walker we're
gonna play some Reaper because I was
requested and then possibly some widow
which is also requested riot six five Oh
says play tanks easy climb lol I mean
yeah I mostly plays Aria in competitive
but a little more devious experiment a
little bit there we go all right yes new
map which has been on PTR and the skins
that they had been teasing over the past
couple days on Twitter as well as when
they showed some of them at Blizzcon
yeah if you want to check the skins out
it's at the beginning of a stream that's
like the first thing we do so you can
scrub back the video players DVR
do you like Hanzo it's my main I don't
personally play Hanzo but I have no
problems with him if that's what you're
asking
always always useful I think huh Cavani
DG a homemade hamburger for dinner soon
that sounds very good I'm getting hungry
it's like our lunchtime yeah
is this how for console as well it
should be Randy Salgado
but somebody I mentioned PSN itself is
down so if PSN is down that could be a
problem obviously but I'm sure when PSN
comes off of maintenance it should be up
I would assume that's part of probably
the reason why PSN might be down here
wok is my first time watching you guys
you're great thank you thanks
you say a few final words the skins are
dope says Cameron Heath yeah the skins
are pretty cool like
different Blizzard games so if you you
know there are skills from these
different Blizzard games which you know
doesn't necessarily would affect certain
people's appreciation and may or may not
like but for me the Diablo seems are
really cool but you know if you are
Diablo fan or Starcraft bandits without
heart storm bought a hearthstone board I
feel like it was oh you can pop the
balloons West entropy saying also first
time watching you guys are awesome it's
gonna be popping them right here oh my
god they're firing to this one
I'm immersing me and hate my life no
nice can yeah well you've gotten some
good ones let's be honest here overwatch
patches is that or events is that
eventually your main character will get
a skin that you'll like and then you go
all in on them that's the cool thing
with these skins this time oh my god is
that there are only a thousand gold so
they're not as expensive to buy and it's
still in question whether or not they
are in loot rock wall in the boxes that
is a good question don't notice me
please you have the heavy footsteps
smart to crawl here
oh that should have been a twofer all
this is bad no just go back to my team
yeah you just don't want to have to deal
with a man see you later
we got a lot flankers Oh daily bits the
new Faris games actually pretty pretty
nice so if you're a fair secondary
definitely check that out it's a
legendary skin oh no Lucio bashing halt
and you just oh my god a bastion oh god
you're good good everyone's dead that's
fine they probably see me no they don't
the gamer
or the gene we're sorry if I butchered
it we're just looking for a channel
doing some new update streams I found
you guys I love to pause the community
that you guys have that you are fun to
watch keep with a great work thanks man
appreciate it I almost escaped that yeah
checking out the new maps fun hard to
say faded vision because there's only
one set of boxes that you can purchase
which is just a standard box and the
standard boxes do have the new sprays
and new player icons but we either just
out of bad luck or whatever in 20 boxes
have not gone in new skin so not sure
whether that's just like a common thing
right now that you can't get the skins
from the boxes or whatnot but maybe
based off the cost that kind of makes
sense since they're so cheap I have no
idea
yeah Albert Fish why is there two of you
maybe because we're twins yeah that's
probably right please say division so if
I have 24 boxes from earlier than this
update they won't have this games I'm
not sure
another cool I'm actually curious if the
boxes from before have the newer sprays
and this fashion is doing work I know
100% technically I should be doing
something about this cuz I'm Reaper dead
veteran pokum or post them says that no
you'll get the old skins if you have the
old crates I wish there's a way to kind
of like differentiate the crates then
since they do look the same as the old
one why doesn't the left one play uh
Joey's a better player than I am and I'm
just here to get the last one yeah I'm
left you're right your stage left
Gustav cyber tour Siebert says oh my god
it just loaded okay I have fun you see
that sorry oh no they're gone you can't
get me because I just got diva suite
thank you for the confirmation there put
grow pega pega nourish nobody's gonna
see this I'm sorry I'm struggling with
the with the name stay apologies Alber
fish who is the dominant twin that's
hard to say it's hard to say it depends
on the situation I think CJ fan how's it
over watch these days still pretty good
CJ always fighting to check out new
skins and enjoy a new man oh nice
starter
oh he he raised the the team record -
Dione oh I don't know what he's doing
he's like don't like Oh what get get a
spread arrowed these skins are here to
stay all year round yep oh my god i got
head shot by the not the spread arrow
but um the sonic holy CMS sorry asking
what's your best game if overwatch
doesn't count what's my best game yeah
like favorite or best and favorite what
game do you feel good at and
what's your favorite game I guess right
now oh geez I feel like Dragon Ball is
your favorite upcoming right now yes and
by that he means Dragon Ball fighter
fighter he just happens to have review
code no that was my moment
Kelly why you just play this because I'm
not I don't play the Reaper I don't know
wait who I shouldn't even think about
that Brandon Shelton it is like
babymetal diva you listen have you heard
of babymetal oh my no I haven't bad at
Reaper doesn't know who that baby metal
at all
it's a Japanese group three girls and a
band they play metal while singing -
like metal music the only the only metal
Japanese miliband I like is a maximum
the hormone I don't know you don't know
them they're so good because they're
like the perfect like blend of j-pop and
metal
this is babymetal is kind of like that
but more metal of anything
oh guy Cochran two years he's doing what
he's supposed to do oh you can kill him
yep wait so do they not drop orbs at all
anymore
no no so a while ago I thought it was
like you get the like little orbs so now
he just does a like just a base I think
it's 15 percent healing forever all on
all damage so like you'll get it just
for if even if you don't kill you'll
still get a felt back soldiers got my
upcoming game if I was this karna say
one I'm looking forward to Dragonball
fighters two but I think I'm gonna go
the Monster Hunter world route so it
kind of filled someone made a good kind
of like analogy or whatever that like it
kind of feels like a sort of Dark Souls
II itch while having destiny type with
loot suit yeah which is like right up my
alley because I love both of those games
so looking forward to playing wants
around the world really wish I hadn't
really copy but I don't
so probably starting Thursday when
everyone else is my main in this game is
I guess like I like playing zenyatta I
like playing Reaper well that's crazy
you just I wanted that bastion he is not
a Reaper main he's just playing Reaper
for the again for the skin and for the
chat
I did not know that Albert fish that
Japan invented animating is the older
country guys good news
so my favorite heroes in yatta reaper
may Joey's he's got a couple don't walk
into that
I like the police diva that's pretty
good one to the pillow
oh this is great no no no no yep the
right where you want them up close and
personal I almost have my old again this
time make sure you're behind them or
above them and drop down this day okay
yeah yeah out healed that okay we're
okay we're okay where'd you go oh wow
didn't you use finger D what she just
pin who are crazy push in the back I
like it
all right does he already use the
scouter arrow I guess these are the type
of plays you gotta make you gotta be the
sky watch them overwatch League I know
should be doing here skirmish it get to
the back lines oh whoops
okay well because he was not he was
doing hello he's doing whole-hog I was
like okay I'll just go behind him and
then everyone gets knocked off the
payload Allen pears I'm not sure how
much the duck World War two resistance
DLC is we will be streaming that next
week I think today they have some
resistance stuff out though like the new
class might be out so I want to check
that out that way that we might be free
don't call me on that not sure
hmph our hat says hey I love your videos
keep the amazing work up thank you
guessing that's Joey I don't make too
many videos anymore this diva and other
hots events cans I think you have to so
you can purchase them now
um they they were only available through
the like the heroes of the storm like
what 10 matches or whatever but now
they're in regular loop boxes and you
can also just buy them hey we got loot
box oh no don't tell me if Monster
Hunter is monthly subscription or once
off daily bits I believe that it's like
a one-time thing but there's gonna be
season pass I think for that so not like
a monthly fee though
opening some boxes here trying to see
trying to see so I told you right
someone did get the D biscuit yeah
so it's possible maybe you're just
having bad luck [ __ ]
I think play one more and then open
boxes if you get in you ski and I'll let
you play one more after that if you
don't get new skins then we'll call fair
enough because we've been on the street
for like two hours it's it's lunchtime
here I'm getting angry what's your worst
hero to come against against I hate a
good Gangi yeah it really depends on who
I'm playing though like good tracer is
also annoying yeah who are you blank I'm
thinking who would be good for this a
new skin yeah we will open more boxes
soon after this match so yeah we're
getting we're definitely getting new
sprays new hero cards it's not new skins
in Heroes okay oh try lucio everyone is
asking if his new skin has new music oh
that's a good thing to test so after
this match I'll go by the skin be tested
we should open the boxes and then buy
this game right
although I'm starting to get really
nervous that there could be anything in
there either we got a bad batch of boxes
or something I don't even know if this
can happen because we've opened so many
yeah we haven't gotten anything but
maybe I wonder if they said anything
about this I'll go look it up on the
tweeters yeah like I hope I hope it does
have new music that'd be cool
Scott music dubstep and Moore says I
bought Lucio and he does not have any
music or it does not have oh well then
your ventures are waiting you can play
well blah know nothing from this let me
see over I think it might be on their
blog because that's where they were they
were detailing all the the new sprays
and stuff
yeah I don't see anything right now
later our ROI PE No thank you pretty
something by all these skins look
amazing but remember they turned down
the drop rates I'm gonna grind for a day
it must be a thing I mean if you had a
lot of gold though like if you I mean if
you play you probably have a surplus of
gold these skins are affordable
I mean relative to you know what they
normally are which is like an event
legend there is normally like 3000 but
these ones are only in 1017 let's go I'm
finally in yeah have fun
thou shalt place in me Hana we do have
this game but we just don't have any
tanks cific has put out their battle tag
if you want to group up with them to
play so didn't make it you're looking
for people to co-op with maybe try out
sippy
yeah sippy we had problems logging in
earlier we finally got through took some
time fortunate enough to be good to go
now I guess
[Music]
Patrick Santiago also putting out their
battle tag so I'm gonna save my goal for
Chinese New Year event in a month that
makes sense daily bits did Hanzo get in
you skin yes it's that kabuki I think
it's kabuki is the name of it that's
pretty cool we showed off that skin
earlier in the stream oh I'm such a big
target shooting my fat body
you could have just punched him Jamie
all that life back play the street Pig
you mean road hog street pig where is
the payload where is everyone
here's our boy hunter wolf yeah yogi and
soon some some people were saying it got
pretty quick once I got to a thousand it
was kind of slow for us but it worked
out just Lucy oh that's not good you
have a junk rat and I'm a Cree and a
widow and they all just died jump crack
got a new epic skin was the caution tape
one Sombra did not kidding he's right
I don't think so though she got a new
emotes which is the one where she like
marrying the marionettes Reaper let the
Holt go too far
kenchi I cannot do that man we're
playing oh lordy we are playing the new
overwatch map as well as checking out
some of the new skins that came out
today this is one of them the Arisa kind
of Starcraft themed skin in the
Starcraft land here you got the Nexus
experience that kind of like Star Wars
you think it looks like a just like a
Alvin we don't have ID there was just a
store oh we don't have that new
barbarian Azaria skin but we do have
some loot boxes you have to open up so
we're hoping to get a new skin or two
the possible there's a new there's a
young Reinhard - which is pretty sweet
if you uh play Reinhardt there's mein
Reinhardt I still think by far for me
anime Reinhardt is my favorite and I
bought that skin ASAP tracer did not get
a new skin surprise surprise surprise
mercy didn't either police see we can
try to show off the hands Oh skin after
I guess we could show I'll try to show
most of the skin these at the end are
all the new legendary skins only a
thousand has joseph Schreyer a Shriner
sorry yes they are only a thousand no
file on get it pile on yes
also you don't have enough pylons
because must require additional pylons
we're cry additional yeah new emo for
tracer but no news get some people were
saying PSN was down Tiffany wolf so that
could be part of the reason why can you
hold in this leoric's tomb yet again
Mohammed Bader asked which can do you
like most I personally like the road hog
skin the most he's the butcher from
Diablo 3 I think this is Joey's favorite
the areso Starcraft skin after I have to
go like a look at them all in a row
there are some good ones though this
time around there's a lot of there's a
decent amount of the skins relative to
all the other events so hopefully
there's one of your mains or secondary
heroes that you guys are interested in
if not you know I think come like in a
month or so I wouldn't be shocked if the
Chinese New Year event drops and you get
some more skin may also got a legendary
skin which kind of is reminiscent of her
short animated short staying with
police say my story means in my language
police master so just say please all
right police descend up but don't
release the police
chassis are saying PSN is down at least
for me on East Coast yeah so probably
won't be able to play until that
finishes so fashion got a cool highlight
intro but no Neeskens yeah he turns from
you guys from tank mode to like normal
two-foot mode
oh I didn't even see when you use though
James Dean says young Reinhardt's gonna
make me wanna play more yeah I mean
that's part of is like having new skins
and skins that you like visually it's
definitely gonna I brought the reaper
closer David that's a wrap yeah new
skins definitely get people to play good
printer are we gonna open some boxes Oh
unless we got to play the other side I
think we're gonna open the box at the
end wasn't it just casually walks in
yeah man look at that that's how you do
I died on the throw Reaper he had a five
killed everything are we gonna open
boxes hopefully we get some new skins if
not we're buying an oak no you know you
don't remember boat no I never did all
right that looked like a promising box
but I know with nothing new gold that's
fine you buy an epic skin with that
which we did already kind of still no
luck this is we're halfway through to
huntress t-shirt guard has a legendary
as well let me say I think I find the
blog post
no new music with Lucio according to the
chat it out though just to make sure is
in yeah that right here
nothing
I like the spray not biased oh there was
any Moira you know the Moira even tell
us one I guess I miss so on there is 12
legendary skins and 5 epic skins so
almost a full roster the new highlight
in shows are honor
whoo that's a pretty good one oh wow
Bastion Winston and soldier under fire
ooh and in that that one's good you did
bashing so the next one would be soldier
someone saying peace war is not down
some people are saying fierce warriors
down so lights out yeah and there's a
Winston one already so nothing yet huh
do I keep going I mean I might as well I
guess I mean like nothing's gonna change
right I mean if it does its kind of
shady cuz we are getting the new sprays
and the player cards but we have not
gotten any skins so we'll show we try to
go through all the skins as the as we
wrap up - I don't know man but someone
did say like the chances are lowest does
that one right but to go an entire
entire set of loot boxes without finding
one possible I think you're not gonna
get one I'm serious man you got a lot of
gold though we started with close to 10k
today there we go get the spray will go
hangzhou after this yeah
Sariah onna mercy to the person who got
the diva skin how many boxes you have to
open legendary was a police car yeah
right that's not bad I mean it's not
great but you know it's not bad oh if
she's an immortal from ok that makes
sense
it just is this bought a set of boxes
has been pretty poor in my opinion get a
lot of legendaries but a lot of gold
fine that's half on the skin or two
epics how do you feel about
microtransactions now I look my personal
stance it has been the same as long as
it's just cosmetic I don't care if
they're in the game nope but I can
understand why people are upset
any news about Diablo 3 nothing new that
I know of other than the anniversary
event that's going on we did a
livestream of that if you're curious
what that looks like
ah we're down to five no we're
definitely not buying more boxes this
sample size has already made me very
wary you can tell who the greedy twin
was in the room play diva with a cats
game we don't have the cat skin right
now equipping all of all these sprays
because there is not a Winston skin by
the way I'm obligated to say that
we are winding down on these little
boxes and we still haven't gotten one I
think it's just safe to say that they do
not know if you got one that or like we
just have really crap luck but 50 boxes
are not getting a new skin is kind of
scared and yes they are just not in
there maybe they should let the people
know I don't know we should find out
though that is kind of crazy anyway do
you need to know which ones are which
these are the epics so here is the
Kabuki hands Oh Hans Oh like his hair is
done up - that looks really nice yeah so
much detail enhance pull police says
you're like wasting money because it'll
be more common to get new legendaries in
one to two weeks because Blizzard just
wants money and doesn't give any of
those skins only lucky once again no
that's not that's just rant it's random
is random pakka
as mentioned Lucio should not have new
music as people had tested already I'll
buy it anyway I like the skin though
like the wood it's only a thousand style
OSA got one from 100 boxes as kg Wow Wow
ok one it's kind of scary we got zero in
50 so there's no soldier 40 are you
looking for new skins yeah sorry
borrow your Bjorn may Reinhardt Swit Oh
road hog no way oh they did get a skin
Mohamed it's the one from her animated
short
I'll go diva just because okay baby no I
know people wouldn't see it you played
diva though or you did yeah I played her
a lot before she kind of got changed and
now she's like super offensive
alright kind of weird last map or game
so that I can go eat lunch
and I'm getting hungry listen what was
Winston his last skin was it this one or
was it the Chinese New Year one that
doesn't count he's just yeah but that's
the last one in uh-oh Nikhil got three
from one hundred I think says Aaron hoho
again she did not get a skin
he got an emo though yep kaiju also
mentioning saying fYI you're you're
looking for a legendary from a way
larger pool of Legendary's chances of
getting it will be Lord that is true
however I feel like Joey has a fair
amount of the skins already in the game
so his chances should have been pretty
decent to get either one new legendary
or one new epic well I guess they really
did lower it like what I mean all things
considered he did get a couple gold
boxes and a couple like legendary skins
he hadn't had before and some epic loot
coal or gold boxes as well so you know
the idea was his last one is what mr. P
Fox says yeah we have Lucy oh we could
check out later - always playing some
video games right yep you have the skin
where's my team
our fish asking what are you gonna eat I
have leftover beef stew that's what I'm
like or 39 maybe the loot boxes doesn't
guarantee one new item yeah since it
isn't like a as it was Caillou was
saying the since the pool of available
items from the boxes are is like the
larger quantity because it's just the
base box base loot box yes then it's
gonna be harder to get new stuff
compared to like event space items
don't forget your rockets yeah I know
that diva skin is dope it says bizarre
one I'm assuming that's how you would
say don't love the diva say the skin
says blue there's it's like pot it's
like one of the biggest cosmetic updates
right Luke box updates I think so don't
heat it up eat it cold and then a lot of
that is like coagulated and I don't
think it'll be as tasty if I don't heat
it up it's almost more like actually in
correcting me to say stews because it
was more of a it almost became a soup
because we put a little bit too much
water in which was totally fine
overwatch again after a month hopefully
you have some gold leftover kazar cuz it
only cost a thousand to buy that skin at
least compared to some of you oh you're
getting coal dust or that's your
coalescence I guess
oh she's dead this time
time to give him that business
nerf it nice a triple and I live yeah
play the game you think spray that
Harvey Stewart can't you try out the
road hog skin I'm new here by the way
welcome I don't think he bought it
which is a shame because that skin is
legit I got actually I will I gotta see
if I have a thousand gold if I have a
thousand I mean I'm snap buying the road
ha the butcher road hog but the good
news is these skins aren't limited so
you should be able to get them whenever
you do get enough gold so that's the
beauty of these skins is they're not
event face so you'll have an opportunity
to earn them no
[Music]
my favorite scan is doofus what is yours
melon head blogs his I believe is ERISA
at least for now wow it's nice I think
those ANOVA to mine is the road hog
the butcher road hog snipe ed well I
know if I played far more I'd probably
really like the ass
dirty s XD says doofus and road hog for
him or her did you play Lucio yet if so
is his music different we have not
played them yet but according to the
chat not new music but we'll test it
soon there's an there's there's one
right there right yeah
watch out for that thank you
oh hello Widow it didn't sound any
different there Jason
Murthy qiyamah saying what there is new
Reaper and Widow yeah
the Reaper skin is only 250 and it's
just an epic Ellis ward there is the
only mercy scale they show the new
emotes please new sub by the way it says
use Yousef use almost like you refresh
good sorry for butchering your name but
are we showed uh the new emotes and
stuff earlier you can check that out
that used to be my favorite Lionheart
skin until until that hot anime right
how it's gonna come out Oh were you
going Ana Wow chow mein just died the
team Wow chummy yeah watch out me is the
nerfs mercy nerf active I don't think
any of the like balance stuff got pushed
through on this patch it was just a map
and the skins right
sweet you think you got the triple yeah
that's probably the game yeah I'll take
it
yeah you master
you got tier be earned by Magni the king
of course why am I not surprised
okay I was - oh okay okay
Vinc sir ZX says my favorite uh is Hanzo
yeah my update is 94%
don't worry sound like you it's Tsun
Tsun no play of the game feels bad what
else we have to do is that it lucio I
guess we'll go into like if it brings us
back into the next round and yeah thanks
everyone for tuning in we got a great
week of stream being ahead of us we have
see if these beta tomorrow we're gonna
have we're gonna start a little later
tomorrow not 11 a.m. but probably 2 p.m.
so if you want to check out a
pirate-themed stream that'll be tomorrow
around 2 p.m. Thursday we should have
Monster Hunter 11 a.m. we try to show
you some later game stuff post story Ben
djenka has been pretty far in the game
might just have John Luke and Ben do
that in in here or maybe it'll be me and
Ben we'll see
and then Friday we're gonna be drying up
all fighters so you'll see us two guys
Duke it out finally because we couldn't
do local last time but he's probably
gonna destroy me so we'll play some
matches maybe either in the beginning or
the end of it and then I'll send him
into the online world or we check out
arcade or something we try arcade on
like hard cuz I think to unlock the
blues you have to really difficult can
mow down hard which is apparently not
that easy so alright we're gonna try the
lucio thing with the music I guess we'll
finish the map so we're not jerks even
though I kind of believe it's just a
quick match isn't it
is they all baton strike you know it I
can always leave bait and switch from
Joey ye your disappoint our team you
should just buy the skins it's really
hard to get the skins out of the loop
boxes says Mohammed Bader yeah we
thought we didn't realize how much
harder was gonna be to get the new skins
so note to everybody in the stream
you're probably better off just playing
the game hoping for gold boxes or
whatever so that you can just buy them
instead of hoping for them to come out
of the box ok so yeah it's the same guys
just say no we bought the skin for just
to find that out see you could have
bought road hog man or nova or barbarian
Zarya or young Rhinehart young
Rinehart's he's sick if he could have
two hammers but they don't wear are they
reading the chat oh I'm not seeing
anyone saying anything about skins so
DOM and I we stream on multiple
platforms GameSpot YouTube twitch
sometimes on periscope we're also going
this yeah sometimes Facebook so we're
just answering questions from multiple
locations so even if you don't see
something being talked about in terms of
on twitch chat there's usually some
stuff going on in YouTube chat as well
unfortunately can't show you the widows
skin from here but it is a Nova from
Starcraft it's pretty much one-to-one
what do you expect Nova to be but in a
first-person shooter I guess oh we
finally I start off ghost in a way in a
way yeah
rip star cocktails this lord shaxx guess
that guy plays destiny
oh all right look you got her and you
somehow got punted into the world
Oh a junker into the sky yeah while I
was uppercutting oh don't you talk about
Starcraft ghost says Bob Jones down and
64 was a long time ago
can you get the new skins with old loot
boxes I don't think you can Lois Ryan
but I'm not 100% positive we haven't
actually tested that like there's no new
Box know that like you can't but you
guys should be able to tell us if you
have old loot boxes and you're getting
like maybe then you sprays and stuff
then you have a chance
how does soon good oh that was like a
triple or quad remember when we were
gonna be leavers and then we got this
guy Vincent I'm not gonna say their last
names too hard says they have the Neo
Reese's game yet how hard so far as this
map to attack the fan I think all the
new maps are a little bit interesting in
the fact that you don't know all the
best routes I guess like like there's
got to be a way around this like
difficult choke point but if there isn't
then you know well you get its really
tall - yeah lift off oh of course not a
good place to be you got all the six
skins dan he bought most of them but I
would say if anything the box is still
got you enough gold to buy a lot of
those skins because like you're roughly
around that amount of gold when we
started this game yeah overwatch critter
says you can't get them from the old
boxes there you go that's what Daniel
Stein said thank you for that info
hmm
sure you can call me Vincent
Beach can't tell if trolling what's in
here oh it's a crown for the black king
yeah okay so can't get new stuff in the
boxes before the update because the
boxes are predetermined for you once you
get the box that's the same thing
technically that was from techno colored
cat and poop stain yeah it makes sense
kind of like the thinking of another
game right now that also does that those
are game it's not coming to my my head
right now
oh yeah that Moira has just done the
strong hand
we've been cool if like I punch the diva
on the way out can I have a shout-out
says SW ace with shout out what's the
best strategy for this map play as a
team smack people with your strong arm
like Joey is right now okay zone them
out what do we got the coccyx ol pylons
here we're at the pylon Terrace right
now nobody's working cupcake slacking
off on the oak grand opening of was
world so I guess they don't want to make
any money off the the big money makers
which is food the other Widow Ulta so
she just sees me look now
Oh triple from the junk rat tire on
arching secure this area Oh smart just
Wukong not smart that's it is what it is
thanks for subbing Vincent appreciate
everyone sitting in if you haven't
subbed or followed do that you guys got
notified when we go live stream almost
every day Oh
as mentioned yesterday in lobby what
kind of pretty much ran its course
so we'll probably try you try to replace
that with something on Wednesdays
we'll see nothing just kind of filler
streams in the interim we read soldiers
had just got off work about to play this
have fun cooter are you got you give me
all right - why million brilliant where
is it back to it that's great you don't
get a you didn't get a free loop box
right I don't think you did No
there we go yeah
I should've saved that bear when we came
out go oh he showed you he showed you
what's up Kendrick Lamar be humble tell
him be humble
nice galaxy productions glad you're also
playing on the players world map
this is the hardest part of the the map
though the torches you think oh good
save good save I'm just gonna go behind
there's that big hill there
oh of course perfect trap
anuraag butter ah yes we are on PC right
now
drunk rice new skin is an epic Kevin
Sosa oh my god kendrick lamar plays
overwatch and he's a junk rack
prematurely user all yeah one could
argue no always doing that somebody's
gotta know where you are taking large
attacks the reads what prebuilt pc
should you forget recommend for
beginners it depends on how much you
want to spend gaming mastered and like
what kind of games you're trying to play
the third time there you go yeah
again
oh yeah just sowed them out I'm on
someone's on the payload yeah nice gg
alright that's a pretty one to go out
cheaper and also don't ask
gamespot why we we have a tech we have a
tech crew here Michael and Jimmy they'll
tell you how to build a cheap PC he
asked me specifically for a prebuilt now
yes of course it's cheaper to build your
own PC but you have to be able to do
that right so generally people that ask
you it like what kind of pre-built PC to
buy means they probably don't want to
make it themselves anyways if you want
to know how to build a cheap PC I'm sure
we have multiple builds and load outs
from our tech guys Jimmy and Michael but
hey that was Blizz world thank you guys
all for tuning in I feel like we got to
do this one time to end our trip oh one
boy we got it we got to play heads up
one more time if you guys didn't see
earlier to end our magical adventure
we're gonna play one more game of heads
up the video game land version I'm doing
here doing it and we're gonna hope to
beat was it nine we're hoping for ten is
there no audio again it's fine Pro Mode
oh sorry
Mario's enemies Mario's main enemy
Bowser and you have to go to his place
castle
so say those together yep in Wonderland
Alice yep
that game where you control people you
make them like you can trap them in
houses Sims yep
oh the game with the two dinosaurs but
it's more like Tetris but not with balls
you shoot them it's a table
yep mm-hmm Ezio Assassin's Creed yep not
the division but kind of in the same Oh
universe not Rainbow six siege who's
who's the guy who's the guy that does
that
it's covert ops oh he writes books yeah
but oh alright
do a barrel roll do a barrel roll [ __ ]
alright
the zombie game for [ __ ] I said for
alright well I think
like they didn't do it that sucks feels
bad but thank you guys all for tuning in
make sure you guys tune in tomorrow for
the sea of thieves tour so stream and
then Thursday we got Monster Hunter
Worlds and then Friday Dragonball
Fighters thank you guys all for hanging
with us playing heads up with us and we
really appreciate it
if you're looking for skins or anything
like that scrub back to the beginning of
this video you'll see all the skins all
the UH most of the emotes we didn't go
through all of them but you can check
that out there and appreciate it until
next time see you guys later Thank You
Joey for playing thank you yeah I hope
you guys have fun we'll see